we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
will go to our next caller from the 918
area code caller what's your name were
you calling from oh wow it's great to
hear from you lettings uh Philip
Andersson with Oklahoma great what's on
your mind well I mean this whole
situation with these constituents acting
upon these Republican Congressmen and
Senators it's become a madhouse
especially in my area a lot of people
are very scared and we really shouldn't
be I guess my main point is that can we
just not call it the Affordable Care Act
anything other than the Affordable Care
Act I guess is mine a lot of these news
outlets are still calling it by a
previous presidents name and people just
don't understand yeah well do i but let
me see if I can dig into this a little
are you saying that we should call the
Affordable Care Act only by that name
and not by the name relative lated to
the prior president because it's causing
some level of confusion or for what
reason don't you want it called that
other thing it's partly because of
confusion some people that don't know
how to read or watch television other
than one channel over here a terminology
like Obamacare and they they think it's
something completely different than what
they already have or what they currently
have which is very affordable for them I
mean it's very it's there it's a form of
propaganda I'd like to say and it's not
very it's not very good yeah positive
founder and also don't realize that it's
actually the same thing that the
Affordable Care Act and Obamacare are
the exact same thing you ask them about
a cortical Care Act
visions they like most of them even
Trump supporters like the provisions
they don't like from the Affordable Care
Act are that if you have more than 50
employees as an employer you have to
offer health insurance and that there's
an individual mandate everything else
they like which is insane because you
need those two provisions in order to
pay for everything else that it does so
I think you're absolutely spot on that
we can't even really have a reasonable
conversation with with many
right-wingers about the Affordable Care
Act because they don't get what's part
of it and what's not part of it and it's
very very dangerous I don't know that
just not calling it Obamacare solves the
confusion but it may well be a part of
it I really do appreciate the call I've
got I want to hear from a couple other
people today before we went out of time
but really really good question
appreciate the call alright thank you
thanks so much